[Musique]
en mai dernier pour la fête des mères un
fils décide d'emmener sa maman au
restaurant mais le déjeuner ne va pas se
passer comme prévu
de 64 ans refuse de les attabler à cause
du voile porté par la mère de famille
une scène filmée discrètement par son
fils la vidéo fait alors très vite le
tour des réseaux sociaux et suscite
l'indignation la femme voilée à de son
côté décider de porter plainte contre la
sexagénaire et toujours traumatisé par
cet événement je me suis sentie très
humilié ça m'a détruite maintenant j'ai
toujours cette crainte quand je vais
dans un restaurant le tribunal de
Bayonne vient de condamner la
restauratrice à un stage de citoyenneté
et à 600 euros d'amende pour
discrimination fondée sur la religion
alors 600 euros d'amende pour avoir
refusé une femme voilée dans un
restaurant trouvez-vous ça suffisant
cette vidéo on va voir la vidéo qui a
été filmée par le fils de la piano
regardez
mais si vous vous avez le droit à ça si
on est client chez vous on est client
vous êtes professionnel vous avez pas
faire ça c'est quoi ça
c'est le jour que vous venez habiller
comme on l'a pris toi comment votre
maman
moi je suis scandalisé je suis
bouleversé le racisme en France coûte
donc 600 euros un acte raciste
maintenant c'est une amende de 600 euros
elle risque de 3 à 5 ans taisez-vous
elle risque rien 5 ans elle pouvait se
le finir elle risque cinq ans de prison
et 600 euros cette femme a une vie
brisée c'était le jour de la fête des
mères vous êtes habillé comme à la
Préhistoire mais c'est presque une
injure raciste c'est incroyable que la
justice ait voulue seulement lui
infliger 600 euros moi je suis pour
fermer le restaurant et lui infliger une
plaque
c'est bouleversant cette histoire
bouleverse alors Béatrice alors moi je
suis contre les discriminations ça me
choque clairement mais je trouve Gilles
d'une hypocrisie parce que franchement
après avoir accepté le Pass sanitaire
qui est des barbelés autour des marchés
de Noël pour empêcher les non vaccinés
de passer etc là où étiez-vous pour
dénoncer les dix criminations sur un
fait en plus faux mais sur des
discriminations biologiques c'est
absolument scandaleux et vous êtes une
hypocrisie et ça me met en colère le
deux poids de mesure qui a dans ce
paysage discriminations
c'est insupportable d'hypocrisie voilà
ça a été une période horrible où vous
avez discriminé Mathieu
alors moi je trouve que c'est comme
toujours dit d'en fait trois tonnes
ça a été très dur elle a été condamnée
en général sont pas appliqués elle a été
condamnée en général la plupart du temps
Gilles pour ce genre de choses c'est un
rappel à la loi il y a eu 600 €, elle a
été condamné et puis Gilles pardon je
vais faire un peu ma Béatrice Rosen mais
arrête de mettre un ordre une hiérarchie
dans ce qui est grave ou pas le racisme
c'est très grave en revanche les petits
problèmes d'homosexualité
ça ne t'a jamais dérangé les t-shirts
portés par les footballeurs
donc pour toi donc effectivement bien
sûr elle a été il a été condamné et
c'est même pas des rappels à la loi il a
eu 600 euros ça va elle a pas non plus
une vie brisée parce que j'ai entré
c'est pour briser de quoi brisé elle le
dit elle-même avait brisée elle va avec
son fils pour la fête des mères elle est
humiliée vous habiller comme un homme
c'est une agression terrible enfin
écoute non moi je comprends
effectivement qu'elle se soit sentie
humiliée et que c'est très très blessant
je trouve évidemment que c'est très
choquant la vidéo c'est raciste et
discriminant moi je trouve que la peine
malgré tout me paraît juste parce qu'il
y a pas que 600 euros d'Amand il y a
aussi 1300 litres du préjudice moral et
ensuite la dame du restaurant doit
effectuer un stage de citoyenneté en vue
de l'apprentissage des valeurs de la
République donc malgré tout c'est une
femme d'un certain âge la femme du
restaurant donc ça me paraît bien et je
trouve que le monde tourne bizarrement
parce que elle est au moment où en Iran
il y a des femmes qui risquent leur vie
et qui sont tués pour vouloir retirer
leur voile je trouve ça malgré tout
qu'on est qu'on a une chance en France
de vivre dans un pays libre grâce à la
laïcité ou que des femmes qui ont envie
de porter le voile soient défendues par
notre loi de la République et voilà et
je trouve que c'est bien de le dire
qu'en France on peut le faire et on peut
être défendu pour ça un pays libre où il
y a quand même un profond malaise on le
voit autour du voile autour de cette
religion qui dérange je trouve que 600
euros même s'il y a eu un préjudice
moral de 1300 euros c'est trop léger
parce que des situations comme ça je
pense que malheureusement il s'en passe
plein en France et là voilà on voit
clairement dans la vidéo que cette
restauratrice elle est raciste c'est pas
elle a juste refusé elle a plein de
clichés de stéréotypes et je pense qu'il
faut les condamner pour éviter que ça se
reproduise parce que malheureusement
mais pourquoi ça te gêne pas pourquoi ça
te gêne pas par exemple que quand tout à
l'heure on parlait du Qatar pourquoi ça
te gêne pas que là-bas par exemple ou
quand gagne mais pas le truc à vérifier
on parle de ceux non non non non non non
non
mais pour répondre c'est comme si tu
disais c'est comme ça
tu disais que tous les gens qui vont
dans le reste dans ce restaurant sont
racistes ça n'a rien à voir arrêtez de
de tout mélanger là la réaction de cette
dame qui est propriétaire du restaurant
est raciste et il faut la sanctionner
sévèrement parce que le racisme c'est
grave
c'est tout ce que dit le code pénalise
une discrimination toute distinction
opéré entre les personnes physiques sur
le fondement leur origine de leur sexe
de l'appartenance à une prétendurance ou
une religion déterminée voilà ce que dit
le code pénal Delphine la dernière fois
on avait le sujet sur les jeunes qui ont
tapé la vieille dame au final eux ils
ont eu que un rappel enfin un stage de
citoyenneté voilà ici on refuse l'entrée
à une vieille dame et clairement c'est
raciste et voilà donc c'est un stage de
citoyenneté plus 600 euros plus 1300
euros donc je comprends pas bien bien on
refuse et mais quand on tape quelqu'un à
quasiment tuer la vieille dame on a créé
un stage de citoyenneté donc encore une
fois en France
c'est la jurisprudence ça veut dire que
ça vaut 600 euros en fait de refuser
quelqu'un dans un restaurant ça vaut 600
€ alors si elle fait 1500 € de chiffre
d'affaires c'est énorme mais je pense à
d'autres restaurants qui font 60 80 000
€ de chiffre d'affaires 600 euros c'est
que dalle ils veulent se dire bah
maintenant avec un voile je peux refuser
quelqu'un qui a un voile ça va me coûter
que 600 euros c'est pour ça que j'aurais
voulu une amende beaucoup plus forte
pour lancer un appel à tout le monde on
ne refuse pas une femme voilée dans un
restaurant c'est tout parce qu'il y a
des restaurateurs qui font 3 4000 € de
chiffre d'affaires par jour 600 balles
pour eux c'est rien finalement
ça me choque bah c'est pour ça que ça
c'est est-ce que est-ce que pour toi
elle mérite elle méritait plus mais bien
sûr que ça m'irait plus une fois d'abord
pour la jurisprudence je veux pas qu'on
envoie le message de dire si tu vires
c'est que 600 balles finalement sur un
chiffre d'affaires de 150000 et c'est un
appel d'air je ne veux pas de ça et en
quoi elle va te déranger si elle est
voilée qu'elle va manger dans son
restaurant avec son fils avant elle va
te déranger quoi 1h30 et après tu
continues ta vie je sais pas au-delà
c'est parce que je veux c'est le choc
qui a suivi et surtout avec son fils
c'est quand même bien sûr c'est
traumatisant je pense que le traumatisme
il est beaucoup plus important que les
600 €. je suis désolé c'est vrai que
derrière c'est vrai que avec ton fils et
c'est compliqué tu m'as fêter la fête
des mères voilà c'est parti pour vous
dire que ça vaut voilà
exagéré non plus attention
avec une ce que j'ai de dire une folle
après j'ai encore prendre une amende
hein non mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
dehors une dame en se disant peut-être
habillé comme la préhistoire c'est pas
possible ça c'est celle-là mais cet
homme dans la loi après je suis je suis
je suis désolé moi je je trouve que le
préjudice moral n'est pas pris en compte
là-dedans je pense que 300 euros mais je
pense que c'est ça je pense que ça vaut
il me semble ce qui était important
aussi c'était que la justice marque le
fait que cette femme était coupable et
hors-la-loi ça c'est très important
parce que ça montre aussi qu'on peut pas
tout faire et qui a un état de droit et
qu'il y a des lois à respecter et
qu'elle était clairement la loi et ça
c'est un signe très fort c'est qu'ils
étaient portés plainte et qu'ils aient
pas jusqu'à on va les manger dans un
autre restaurant je pense à son fils le
plus c'est voir sa mère
je suis désolé non mais son comportement
et en plus il témoigne d'un racisme
décomplexé c'est-à-dire malheureusement
déjà il y a plein de gens qui pensent ça
mais en plus elle elle le dit en détente
à des clients vous êtes habillés comme
la préhistoire je suis désolé le voile
c'est légal ça me dérange personne
pourquoi on les fait chier comme ça moi
je suis comme comme à chaque fois c'est
vrai que voilà nous on donne la parole à
tout le monde ici on est je pense
l'émission la plus ouverte du PAF et ça
dérange beaucoup euh mais c'est vrai que
nous on part du principe que on a envie
de tout le monde s'exprime on a envie
que tout le monde moi je pense pas que
cette dame qui va être dans un
restaurant voilé va gêner le bon
fonctionnement du restaurant on va gêner
des personnes ils vont manger à côté
d'elle moi je suis désolé moi je pense
que voilà c'est c'est vraiment ça c'est
pour moi ça c'est c'est voilà ça c'est
un faux sujet voilà je pense que
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que ça va vous
empêcher de manger d'avoir une femme qui
est qui est voilée à côté de vous non
est-ce qu'elle va vous déranger bah non
non voilà donc c'est ça le truc c'est
que moi je pense à partir du moment où
dérange pas les autres je suis désolé on
peut et on contrepartie on n'est pas par
exemple pour les restaurants
communautaires où on impose aux femmes
d'être voilée aussi mais c'est pas ça
ressembler il faut nous rassembler mais
il faut pas que nous exclure et je tiens
à dire Cyril que la famille de la date
exemplaire il y avait un appel au
boycott qui a été lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux non seulement de ce restaurant
mais de tous les restaurants de la côte
basque quasiment et bien la famille a
pris la parole pour dire arrêtez arrêtez
continuez à aller dans ce restaurant
nous ne sommes pas pour le boycott et
continuer à aller au restaurant sur la
côte basque ils ont porté l'affaire en
justice mais après ils ont été très très
bien voilà
qui va rajouter quelque chose Jean-Marie
c'est pas entendu toi là non mais le
voile il voit les voiles déjà si jamais
c'est comme ça et tout le visage tout
c'est complètement différent de là on a
le visage tout entier de cette femme qui
a parfaitement le droit de porter ce
voile donc les personnes qui considèrent
que c'est ces gens-là sont pas les
bienvenus ils font non seulement une
faute mais il mérite une amende
effectivement on en peut plus de c'est
je vous dire
il y a de la haine là partout là en ce
moment c'est insupportable c'est c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut pas ici et je le
vois c'est vrai que là il y a la France
qui est qui est qui est coupée dans tous
les sens et c'est vrai que les gens moi
je trouve ce prennent la tête pour rien
c'est devenu insupportable les gens se
prennent la tête pour rien et je vais
vous dire tout le monde a envie de vivre
ensemble heureux et d'arrêter de d'être
voilà dans des communautariste de dire
voilà un tel porte un voile moi comme tu
dis moi quand j'étais quand j'étais à
l'école on me disait pas je suis avec un
pote je suis avec une copine qui envoie
ou je suis avec un pote qui porte une
qui part autre chose on rigolait
ensemble on sait même pas à ça et
aujourd'hui
il y avait moins de revendications
fait qu'aujourd'hui bah un noir peut
faire des blagues sur les Noirs un gay
sur les gays un gros sur les gros machin
et que le fait religieux était beaucoup
moins
présente ça c'est si on les exclut qu'on
accepte pas toute la communauté entre
nous sans différence que les gens vont
se replier sur eux-mêmes il faut
accueillir tout le monde on a un creuset
qui est génial il faut pas le fragmenter
sinon ce sera plus la France qu'on aime
faut faire attention à ça il faut donner
la parole tout le monde c'est comme je
vous dis moi je ne supporte pas aussi et
ces journalistes je vais vous dire on
nous reproche ici on nous a reproché je
le dis d'avoir des des femmes voilées
dans le public des femmes voilées que
j'avais fait jouer des des femmes
voilées ici je vais vous dire on
continuera à faire ce qu'on veut et on a
un espace de liberté ici on nous propose
on nous reproche aussi d'un autre côté
d'inviter des représentants du
rassemblement national forcément on
donne la parole à tout le monde et je
vais vous dire et moi je le redis je ne
vous dirai jamais votez pour Mélenchon
ou voter pour au Marine Le Pen ou voter
pour Emmanuel Macron votez pour qui vous
voulez je le dis à chaque fois ça je les
donneurs de leçons qui il faut pas
recevoir un tel il faut pas voter pour
un tel faut pas faire si faut pas faire
ça il se met pas votre place tous ces
journalistes qui sont derrière leur
petit ordinateurs à écrire et qui sont
tranquillement chez eux comme nous
d'ailleurs parce que nous ici on est
très bien l'outil va se mentir ils sont
pas à votre place donc quand il y a des
gars qui stigmatisent des mecs qui
votent pour le RN et qui disent ces
gens-là sont nourris mettez-vous à leur
place 5 minutes et mettez-vous à leur
place des gens qui votent pour Mélenchon
mettez vous à la place de gens qui
votent pour les écolos mettez-vous mais
arrêtez de donner des leçons les
Français ne veulent plus de leçon ils ne
veulent plus qu'on leur dise qu'il faut
regarder ce qu'il faut écouter ce qu'il
faut lire ce qu'il faut penser les
Français veulent penser par eux-mêmes et
je vous dis le succès de cette émission
rend fou les gens parce que justement
la bien-pensance est les bobos de gauche
voudraient qu'on reçoive que des gens de
gauche avec des pipes qui viennent nous
parler histoire
non mais c'est vrai et qui viennent nous
dire et qui viennent nous dire le vaccin
c'est génial il faut mettre que le
vaccin alors le vaccin c'est peut-être
génial mais s'il y a des gens qui disent
le bassinet il y en a qui disent que
c'est Moyen-Âge la Coupe du Monde c'est
vraiment pas bien ou bah il y a des gens
qui nous lissent pas bien des gens qui
nous disent que c'est bien les donneurs
de leçons on en peut plus le RN
attention le RN faut pas les inviter sur
le plateau ah non nous on les invite il
y a des contradicteurs en face je vais
vous dire et ce qui rend fou c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le plus grand
espace de liberté du PAF et aujourd'hui
les gens comprennent et le succès de
TPMP ça rejoint ça c'est que ça les
emmerde parce qu'ils se disent bah nous
on se met des barrières et on n'a pas le
succès de TPMP donc merci à vous en tout
cas et sachez que ça sera toujours un
espace de liberté ici
où tous les gens
ou tous les gens seront les bienvenus et
on ne stigmatisera jamais personne ici
sur ce plateau sachez le nous on accepte
tout le monde sauf les cons ou les bobos
qui se la racontent